you weren't like this segue you're what
I'm going to go for it any awkward one
of the things that the Trump campaign
did was exactly that he connected with
hearts he managed to get emotional
campaign trail I'm sure you were at the
rallies I was at the rallies they were
noisier and they were more passionate
than any other one that I attended and I
did a lot so the question is if the left
wants to get back into the business of
winning does it have to find an
emotional message of politics does that
sound like the right way or D would you
consider that to be a sort of a populist
trap how would you know I think it's a
very important insights one that I share
I'm a big believer only that people
actually don't listen through their ears
they listened through their stomachs and
if you as a leader or reporter connect
to someone on a gut level their usual
attitude is don't bother me with the
details and if you don't connect with
them on a gut level you can't show them
enough details can I see that third
point you made just one more time and so
what was Hillary Clinton's most oft
quoted line in this campaign visit my
website www Laurie claimed it was as
connecting at the gutless visit my
website and and I was making this point
of a friendly on weasel tier is a
brilliant writer and Leon weasel appear
once described Utah crabby in the
Israeli prime minister as a bastard for
peace okay and I think that's what the
left needs in America they need a
someone who can connect with people on a
gut level but take them in a progressive
direction forward not where Trump wants
to take them which i believe is to a
dark corner backward and that's what the
left needs Obama had some of that not
all of it Bill Clinton had some of that
but I don't see anyone on the national
stage in America today who really has
that